Today's classrooms reflect the increasingly
mobile society we live in.
The student population is becoming more diverse
and non-native speakers constitute a greater
portion of classrooms
than in previous generations, or even just
a few years ago.
Parent-teacher conferences are a key instrument
for engaging parents
with their children's teachers and the school
community.
But what if parents aren't fluent in the language
of their child's school?
How can they gain an accurate picture of their
child's progress?
How can they target areas for improvement
when there's
a communication gap with the instructor?
Today, Microsoft offers a groundbreaking new
tool that bridges the gap
between parents and the teachers responsible
for their child's education.
Microsoft Translator provides real-time translation
in a free, easy-to-use tool
that works on any device with web capability.
(Teacher speaking) "Welcome.
Thank you so much again for coming today."
(Parent replies in Spanish)
(Teacher speaking) "Your son is very kind.
He's doing really well in my class."
(Parent replies in Spanish)
(Teacher speaking) "Do you have any other
questions for me?"
Going beyond the classroom, there are situations
in education
where parents can benefit from real-time translation
into their native language.
When parents are able to efficiently touch
base with school staff,
navigating school practices and policies becomes
effortless.
There are many interactions between families
and schools
that are simplified with Translator.
The set-up from Microsoft Translator is so
quick and easy.
Just visit aka.ms/translatoredu to learn more
and download the app.
Then start talking.
Your conversations await.